[Musique]
il ya quelques années des chercheurs
québécois ont inventé un produit quasi
miraculeux destiné à remplacer les
prothèse du genou
la compagnie québécoise s'est toutefois
fait damer le pion d'une bien étrange
manière
après avoir été saoul mentionné entre
autres par des fonds publics
certains parlent même d'une faillite
orchestrée pour acheter la version à bas
prix enquête sur la disparition de ce
qui s'annonçait comme un fleuron
québécois
le quart gel et quasi miraculeux pour
les genoux le premier patient opéré avec
ce produit est une star serge savard
l'ex défenseur et directeur général des
canadiens aimeraient
était un cobaye de l'avs a tellement
confiance ça se produise que j'ai
accepté de me faire opérer
conçu par des chercheurs d'ici
subventionnés par les contribuables
canadiens
le cartel a attiré de nombreux petits
investisseurs québécois qui ont tout
perdu
la compagnie qui a mis au monde de
produits annoncé son intention de faire
faillite ou près du but quand on lit
tous les documents ça semble être une
fête orchestrée après de multiples
rebondissements en cours une mystérieuse
invasion de domicile
des démissions inexpliqué l'invention et
ses profits échappe aux québécois on
avait entre les mains un produit
recomposera c'est l'extrême on parle
aussi pour la planète on parle de
millions
[Musique]
il y à une quinzaine d'années c'était
l'âge d'or de la biotechnologie on
travaille avec les cellules deux êtres
humains lui même un ancien professeur de
l'école polytechnique de montréal met au
point le cargel une alternative aux
prothèse du genou
sa compagnie biosyntech prétend
carrément regénérer le cartilage
endommagé à la source
biosyntech a mise au point à biot gel
dans la blessure du cartilage le gel
devient solide et les cellules encapsulé
commencent leur travail de réparation
les contribuables ont aidé la compagnie
a développé son produit miracle 5
millions $ un crédit d'impôt 6 millions
en prêt d'investissement québec et de la
banque de développement du canada
sans compter les nombreuses bourses de
recherche octroyés entre 1995 et 2010
polytechnique a reçu plus de 13 millions
de dollars pour effectuer de la
recherche dans des domaines reliés aux
champs d'intérêt de biosyntech les
chercheurs se sont également tournés
vers la bourse pour financer leur
compagnie et tenir le coup pendant que
les essais cliniques visant à obtenir le
feu vert de santé canada se dérouler
charles beaudoin et vincent blais ont
acheté des actions de biosyntech dès la
fin des années 90 on était actionnaire
on n'était pas brillé par donc oui
j'avais un sentiment d'appartenance à
cette compagnie là les employés étaient
québécois la technologie québécoise nos
relations universitaires et des
québécoises que le bus était de
développer l'accompagnement québec vous
personnellement combien vous avez
investi une somme assez importante pour
parce que j'étais là depuis le début
c'est à dire on parle en termes de santé
en 2003 serge savard se fait opérer au
cargel alors que le produit n'est pas
encore commercialisé santé canada
accorde parfois des permissions
spéciales aux malades qui comme serge
savard ne répondent pas aux traitements
reconnus
j'avais des problèmes de réseau via le
marché je veux dire à montélimar et jure
une qualité de vie qui était quand même
assez restreint il témoigne publiquement
de l'efficacité du produit
schlumberger son exemple en ainsi
d'autres comme annette arsenault à se
faire opérer avec une permission
spéciale le quart gel a carrément changé
la vie de la septuagénaire avant le
carnage il se tait points de vie après b
j'ai pu recommencer à vivre normalement
qu'un cadeau fait tout pu réaliser des
rêves que j'avais appartenait biosyntech
en profite pour mousser son produit
tablant sur le témoignages
dithyrambiques de la patiente
toute cette publicité attire de gros
investisseurs le fonds de solidarité de
la ftq le fonds d'investissement
proquest et piramal une multinationale
indienne mais d'autres joueurs
vraisemblablement mal intentionnés
tendre l'oreille
une autre affaire d'invasion de domicile
survenue cette fois à l'avant la nuit
dernière un couple a été attaquée ligoté
par trois suspects au mois d'août 2006
un haut dirigeant de biosyntech que nous
ne pouvons identifier était acquis chez
lui en pleine nuit
les agresseurs sont arrêtés au procès la
victime explique que les motifs de
l'invasion de domicile n'ont jamais été
clair pour lui
j'ai dit au dews you want candy
ils ont dit no we will rock you know car
ils ont dit qu'ils vont m'attacher me
bander les yeux me mettre une cagoule et
qu'ils allaient m'enlever
terry damas café un des cinq agresseurs
a donné un peu plus d'un 10 lorsqu'il a
été accusé
est ce que vous en ferez pourquoi on
sera chez ces gens là ont du plomb de
bansko
ce qu'expose est un être ou aller
chercher les documents l'histoire de son
métier la business c'est biosyntech
certain petit investisseur comme vincent
blais sont interrogés les questions des
enquêteurs
à ce moment là semblait porter sur un
acte commandé par un groupe non
identifié mais on cherchait toujours
selon les enquêteurs à mettre la main
sur des documents qui auraient prenant
procurer une information stratégie pour
commanditaires dollars
les policiers sont incapable de creuser
l'histoire du vol de documents
les agresseurs seront finalement
condamné seulement pour l'invasion de
domicile
serge savard qui s'est recyclé dans le
monde des affaires depuis sa retraite du
hockey c'est un jour conseil
d'administration de biosyntech dès le
début des années 2000 tout le temps que
j'ai été sur le conseil d'administration
de biosyntech on était de les réunir
pour 0 on a de l'argent pour jeu ce soir
huit morts de mort c'est comme ça en
2008 des fonds privés renflouer les
coffres de la compagnie un nouveau venu
island le fonds de solidarité de la ftq
ainsi que papa ses propos est deux fonds
américains dans lesquels la ftq investit
ils demandent cinq des neuf sièges à la
table du conseil d'administration dont
un pour un membre indépendant désigné
par la ftq
c'est une pratique courante mais c'est
un char n'apprécie pas il voit le
contrôle de la compagnie échapper aux
administrateurs de la première heure moi
j'ai démissionné parce qu est ce que j
ai fait je racontais l'abstraction
hooker sa voiture neuve qui contrôlait
la ftq et elle est liée aux coûts
instance
c'est quelque chose qui s'est fait dans
la table cette prise de contrôle de lal
fond j'ai pris mes sauts du coup la part
des petits actionnaires dans la
compagnie passe de 75 % à 35 %
mais charles beaudoin ne s'inquiète pas
en 2008 c'est ce qu'on pensait qu'on
manquera pas de fond à cause qu'on avait
des bons partenaires avec les poches
profondes
[Musique]
au retour après une bonne nouvelle de
mauvaises nouvelles
laurence posait de sérieuses questions
qu'est ce qui se passe avec cette
compagnie là tout va bien
les gens entre les deux missions
[Musique]
l'année 2009 s'annonce positive au
printemps la banque laurentienne évalue
que biosyntech vaut entre 77 et 180 2
millions de dollars juin 2009 une
analyse intérimaire démontre que le
cartilage des 22 premiers patients
opérés au quart gel est sensiblement
améliorée la compagnie met un communiqué
en juin 2009 ont eu les résultats de nos
essais cliniques qui prouvaient par un
laboratoire indépendant que notre
système de cars gel fonctionner donc
c'est la meilleure nouvelle que
biosyntech a jamais eu
le communiqué est écrit par michel
lagueux président et chef de la
direction de biosyntech et matthew chef
directeur scientifique
ce dernier a accepté de nous parler au
téléphone seulement
encore aujourd'hui il ne comprend pas
pourquoi certains membres du conseil
d'administration étaient réticents à
publiciser la bonne nouvelle au moment
des maîtres le communiqué il me semblait
qu'il n'était pas content pour moi
c'était le meilleur communiqué de presse
de toute l'histoire de la compagnie on a
dû sabler le champagne
mais ce n'était pas comme ça plusieurs
membres du ca me poser des questions
comme pourquoi est ce qu'on est sûr que
c'est le bon moment
ce genre de question qui me faisait
penser que peut-être ne voulait pas
qu'on sort que le communiqué quoi qu'il
en soit dès que le communiqué est émis
la valeur de l'action de biosyntech
monte en flèche
le titre tous ma mémoire est bonne est
passé d'environ 23 joue à près de 32
joue sous telle annonce de nouvelles
donc le marché réagissait comme vous ce
alors justement contribué à créer une
excitation chez actionnable dix jours
plus tard nouveau communiqué on annonce
la démission du président michel lagueux
closes pour de sérieuses questions
qu'est ce qui se passe à ce conte avec
cette compagnie low tout va bien les
gens attelé démissionne
michel lagueux n'a jamais retourné nos
appels mais selon un article publié par
le canal argent il aurait motivé son
départ précipité en disant qu'il ne
voulait pas faire de prison et que
l'information émanant de biosyntech
étaient manipulés par le conseil
d'administration
j'ai jamais eu la réponse exacte à
savoir pourquoi monsieur legault avait
démissionné à ce moment là j'ai trouvé
ça très vacataires le communiqué de sa
démission insiste sur les problèmes
financiers de biosyntech disant même
douter que la société puisse continuer
ce que nous on croit c'est que ces
restes relançant pied pour nuire à la
compagnie le communiqué est défait
construit pour semer le doute quant à la
capacité des entreprises de générer de
revenus futurs
messaoud abda et aux spécialistes de la
lutte contre la criminalité financière
il croit lui aussi que le deuxième
communiqué était intentionnellement
alarmiste le fait que vous disiez que
cette entreprise a des problèmes
puisqu'elle va avoir encore plus de
problèmes sans mettre en contraste le
brevet puis les essais cliniques bild le
la véracité plus le succès du produit
qu'ils valent sur le marché c'est clair
que la manipulation pour moi était
visible centre et un contexte incertain
tout la compagnie sont amenés financer
la restructuration
on peut faire redescendre un tissu de
mauvaise humeur
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé
après la publication de ce communiqué
négatif l'action de biosyntech chute à
14 cents
le lendemain la compagnie et mais de
nouvelles actions selon des règles
prévues plusieurs mois auparavant et qui
favorise ceux qui ont déjà beaucoup
d'action les fonds d'investissements se
retrouve avec une part encore plus
grande des actions de biosyntech plus le
prix l'action des bords plus recevait
une petite élection important que ça
augmente de leur participation dans
l'organisation
pendant cette période le volume
inhabituel de transaction autour de
l'action de biosyntech attire
l'attention de l'autorité des marchés
financiers mais au terme de son enquête
bla mf ne trouve rien de répréhensible
septembre 2009
selon un document remis aux actionnaires
sept des neuf candidats du conseil
d'administration ont été proposées par
le fonds de solidarité de la ftq et les
fonds privés d'investissement
deux de ces candidats sont des membres
indépendants désignés par la ftq
biosyntech est vraiment dans le rouge
il cherche un acheteur pour renflouer
ses coffres malgré tout le conseil
d'administration embauche une chef des
directions à 400 mille dollars par année
salaires et bonus compris n'ont jamais
ralenti les dépenses on n'arrive pas à
zéro d'un compte en banque ça le voir
venir l'ont vu venir ils l'ont planifié
depuis un an la compagnie garde même
chercheur payé à ne rien faire
celui ci a décrit devant les tribunaux
comment ils passer le temps je suis le
seul maintenant qui soit disant fait de
la recherche et développement mais je le
fais pas parce que j'ai personnes pour
travailler avec moi mais alors qu'est-ce
que vous faites de vos journées je lis
beaucoup
j'écris je révise les articles
scientifiques on m'envoie je quitte mes
journées comme ça novembre 2009 la
compagnie publie ses dernières bonnes
nouvelles
l'analyse intérimaire des images de
résonance magnétique de 41 patients
opérés au quart gel est positive après
la pause mise en faillite contestées
quand on vit tous les documents
ça semble être une fête orchestrée sur
le principe légal des finances il n'y a
pas faute mais ce n'est pas logique
[Musique]
12 mai 2010 qu'au théâtre
biosyntech annonce son intention de
faire faillite
biosyntech était une des entreprises bio
médicales les plus prometteuses du
québec
pourtant le conseil d'administration de
biosyntech décide de placer
l'accompagner sous la protection des
tribunaux
pris par surprise un actionnaire décide
de contester la mise en faillite
ils se retrouvent devant les tribunaux
pour stopper le processus
appuyé par le fondateur de la compagnie
et d'autres petits investisseurs mais le
délai qu'on donne aux acheteurs
potentiels qu'ils pourraient racheter
biosyntech et la sauver de la faillite
était normalement pour convention six
jours
ma compréhension c'est quand naît sous
la protection de la loi sur les
faillites
c'est pour éviter une vente de feu puis
c'est pour même maximiser la valeur des
actifs
montre éléments dérangeants au moment où
la compagnie a été mise en faillite
les tests cliniques venait tout juste
d'être complété selon un document
interne sur lequel nous avons mis la
main la compilation finale des résultats
devait être terminé début septembre
et c'est ce qui aurait donné sa pleine
valeur à la compagnie et cela le conseil
d'administration ne pouvait l'ignorer
ça fait pas de sens ça fait des années
qu'ils roulent les essais qu'il roulait
les implantations clinique qui l'ont de
2,2 de bonnes rétroaction que le produit
répond bien dans dans le corps des donc
d'aider des malades et ainsi de suite
et à trois mois des si tout à coup donc
de mettre la compagnie en faillite
c'est clair que ça ça ne fonctionne pas
que pendant le procès le juge c'est en
lui aussi du moment choisi
c'est comme si on était tous pressés de
la vence compagnie on veut surtout pas
que ça prenne la valeur qu on va faire
un parallèle on voit prendre un
constructeurs d'immeubles
il donne 40 étages il ya 39 étages de
construire on s'assoit pas avec le
créancier pour dire
on fini tu le 40e ou bedon mais la pelle
mécanique de 2
je trouve que c'est une bonne
comparaison même un peu faible je dirais
que l'immeuble défini marqué la porte et
on a décidé qu'on mettra par rapport
[Musique]
et ce n'est pas parce que biosyntech
avait dépensé plus que la normale
qu'elle a été mise en faillite avec 76
millions d'investis dans le
développement du quart gel du syntec
était bien en dessous de la moyenne pour
arriver à mettre en marché un produit
comme le quart gel ça coûte entre 94 et
300 millions de dollars selon les études
que nous avons consultés je peux pas
m'expliquer que quelqu'un qui a les
poches beaucoup plus profond que moi
arrête je peux pas me l'expliquer on est
à trouver on vient de jeter 76 millions
dans le fleuve et vous allez même
pouvoir investissement québec la mouche
ou estomaqué on n'est pas tenté riez
riez riez en fait
investissement québec venait de prêter
un million à biosyntech ce qu'elle ne
fait pas avec les compagnies qui risque
de ne plus être en affaires dans la
prochaine année l'organisme était même
prêt à allonger un autre million mais
biosyntech ne s'en est jamais prévalu en
cours
le syndic de faillite fait valoir que
les démarches entreprises par la
compagnie pour trouver un partenaire ou
un acquéreur l'année précédente n'ont
pas porté fruit et il aurait fallu
remettre encore au moins 10 millions
pour amener produit à la
commercialisation
écoutez la la compagnie dont on parle
avait des dettes elle n'avait plus
liquidités elles n'étaient plus capables
de faire face à ses obligations
elle rencontrait plusieurs critères pour
la définir comme étant insolvable
pour maintenir la compagnie en vie
pendant les trois prochains mois
critiques ça aurait pris au minimum 2
millions 500 mille dollars
le fondateur de la compagnie amine
selmani propose d'hypothéquer sa maison
pour ce montant je suis impliqué corps
et âme dans cette compagnie j'ai fait un
plan un plan détaillé pour finir et
sortir les résultats je travaillerai son
salaire ce qui m'aurait semblé logique
s'est offert une assemblée spéciale des
actionnaires dire est ce qu'un haut
qu'en bas
si ce phénomène lost faits s'étaient
produits on a retrouvé la compagnie
l'avocat de biosyntech fait alors valoir
que ces petits actionnaires n'ont pas
choisi la bonne défense juridique et
qu'ils sont devant une cour de faillite
qui analyse strictement les chiffres
c'est une série de reproches qui sont
adressés au conseil d'administration
est ce que ça change la situation
d'insolvabilité non il ya toujours un
compte de banque
les juges seront finalement cette
opinion et autorise la vente de
biosyntech reste à trancher laquelle des
offres d'achat il faut accepter
piramal et proquest de compagnie qui
siège depuis longtemps au conseil
d'administration ont soumissionné
quand proquest le partenaire de la ftq
en biotechnologie réalise qu'il risque
de perdre les enchères il augmente son
offre d'achat 2 millions de dollars au
beau milieu des procédures judiciaires
proquest peuvent pas nous dit on n'avait
pas d'argent ils ont fait une offre à 4
millions un peu moins de 4 millions il y
aura chéri d'un million par la suite le
juge refuse la surenchère de dernière
minute c'est piramal qui remporte la
mise
et met la main sur biosyntech pour 4
millions de dollars trois semaines plus
tard la compagnie indienne indique
qu'elle est maintenant à six sur un
marché de 500 millions de dollars
uniquement en amérique du nord qui a
provoqué la faillite de biosyntech c'est
le conseil d'administration en cours
il a beaucoup été question d'une dette
de 17 millions de dollars qui aurait été
déterminante
à qui était dû cet argent en grande
partie au fonds de solidarité et à
propos est en plus faible proportion aux
autres fonds privés et septfonds décider
du sort de la compagnie car ils étaient
majoritaires au conseil d'administration
on parle d'initiés contrôlant conseil
d'admistration eux avaient accès à de
l'information privilégiée en est un
initié dès pouvait bien entendu prendre
des décisions d'affaires basés sur
l'information les honneurs et selon
notre spécialiste les 17 millions dus
aux fonds privés n'était qu'un prétexte
écoutez quand vous et la taille de la
qualité des investisseurs qui a qu'un
petit l'union ses quelque 7000 est une
goutte d'eau dans la rivière
je sais que c'est clair que c'est
patrick minot qui mettrait en fait quand
vous le regardez de longue haleine toute
la séquence des événements
ça ressemble beaucoup à une
orchestration de mise en faillite pour
s'accaparer allons qu'un brevet je suis
totalement d'accord avec cette
interprétation là quand on vit tous les
documents ça semble être une fête
orchestrée sur le principe légal et
financier yapi yahya baya par faute mais
c'est juste que ce n'est pas logique
on peut se demander pourquoi le fonds de
solidarité de la ftq qui avait investi 9
millions $ dans biosyntech ne s'est pas
opposé à la mise en faillite
certains croient que le fonds à jouer
quitte ou double
inspirant que son partenaire proquest
puisse au moins racheter la compagnie en
faillite
il perdait 9 millions mais si proquest
acheter la compagnie perd d'un point 9
millions
c'est la seule façon que je peux voir
qu'il laisserait le dossier mourir comme
ça
dale scott croque ouest qui avait échoué
à investir et face aux vives la
compagnie ou prendre le risque d'avoir
ça pour ça de la compagnie pour très peu
d'argent
lyon décidément pris le deuxième choix
pourquoi il n'a répondu à aucune de nous
demande explique m
[Musique]
à la fin nous appellent à la responsable
du dossier semblait déranger
island et pappas n'ont pas plus répondu
à nos questions
quant au fonds de solidarité de la ftq
son porte parole soutient qu'il est fou
de laisser entendre que le fonds de
solidarité et provoqué la faillite de
biosyntech dans le but de racheter
l'entreprise à plus bas prix et que
cette théorie démontre une profonde
méconnaissance du processus de la loi
sur la faillite
certains sont toutefois critiques envers
le fonds de solidarité tout ce qu'on
nous a pas donné l'impression que la ftq
jouer son rôle de partenaire financier
dans l'avant sur un fond qui s'en va sur
le site internet 1 euro d'accompagner
façon financière et stratégique des
compagnies québécoises qui veulent créer
des projets créateurs de valeur
depuis la mi mai 2012 piramal annonce
qu'elle a le feu vert pour
commercialiser le quart gel on ira au
siège social de mumbai en inde
on parle maintenant de marcher deux
milliards de dollars c'est un chauffeur
qui avait également des actions dans la
compagnie a perdu un demi million
charles baudoin et vincent blais des
centaines de milliers de dollars chacun
je suis content que le produit existe
c'est un produit qui soulage énormément
donc ces gens alors à bout de ligne les
aurores faire une solution donc ça j'en
suis très fier que quelqu'un d'autre en
cause tous les profits de saut j'en suis
très frustré ben ali contre ibm par le
biais du semo vestaires par le biais de
subventions à la recherche par le biais
de crédits d'impôt généreux cet acte
généreux
la ftq a contribué au développement
biosyntech est à mon avis n'en récolte
report tous les fruits
piramal répond que les contribuables en
auront pour leur argent
la multinationale produira le quart gel
à laval chartré l'emploi ici au québec
on est très heureux de ce sont les gens
de pires amants sont très heureux à
leurs questions n'empêche d'un point de
vue fiscal profite s'il y en a 100
peuvent s'en aller à mumbai alors que
certaines compagnies aient des
propriétés québécoises le portrait
aurait été tout autre
c'est vrai pour toutes les sociétés
[Musique]
piramal pourrez avoir accès à un nouveau
marché celui des genoux canadien
si tout va bien le cartel pourrait
obtenir le feu vert de santé canada
cette année
[Musique]